mais alors qu'est-ce qui explique vous
étiez stalinien d'abord le sentiment de
culpabilité d'un intellectuel bourgeois
qui devient intellectuels
révolutionnaires qui donc prendre les
risques cet engagement politique et qui
découvre que des parures critiques c'est
à dire qu'au départ il conçoit très bien
le parti est un instrument delà de la
révolution mais un instrument pas
forcément une église qui peu à peu en
grande partie par ce besoin qui a fait
le populisme et qui a fait l'ouvriérisme
il ya fait toute cette école depuis le
19e siècle de se mettre vraiment au
service du peuple
une phrase que les maoïstes emploie
encore que jamais de son créneau fait à
son club devrait m'en avait dit reid un
certain nombre de vertus essentielles de
l'intellectuel critique
ils ont des vertus négative sans
lesquels il n'y a pas d'intellectuels
alors ça c'est un processus qui prend
qui prend son temps mais je reviens de
l'action tout à l'heure finalement
l'homme politique était beaucoup moins
stalinien que l'intellectuel bourgeois
devenue commune et c'est à dire à ce que
l'homme politique à part d'une 53 il a
eu la chance d'abord donc sanchez de
travailler après la mort de staline de
faire carrière politique après la mort
de staline et à la période disons de la
déstabilisation provisoire du 20ème
congrès donc dans une bataille contre le
stalinisme
même s'il était partiel et comme
maintenant c'est un vieux l'excusé -
oubliez de dire que c'est votre nom de
veliko sanchez c'est votre nom
le camp destiné de clandestinité en
espagne il ya quand même à l'histoire
moi qui me stupéfient rijkaard alors qui
est bien bien pires que quelques les
poèmes
c'est l'histoire de ce tchèque qui
s'appelle joseph vente franck alors vous
l'avez connu à buchenwald il est
condamné à mort pour je prends pour
avoir travaillé pour la gestapo rendez
vous dit c'est pas possible
et malgré tout vous dit rien je suis
militant de base en 52 je ne dis rien
parce que je sais ce moment là que si je
vous dis la vérité je sera exclu du
parti
et c'était votre ami c'était mon commun
et c'est bien pour ça que je son bien
sans lui ce n'était pas crédible
ce n'était pas crédible je ne croyais
pas non plus alors se donne toujours des
arguments on se dit peut-être que lui
est innocent dans un groupe de gens qui
ne sont qu ils sont pas innocents je
suis en train d'inventer de donner des
raisons qui sont de mauvaises raisons
mais mais ça se passe en 52 et en 56 le
rapport secret de khrouchtchev fait
comprendre que tout ça est faux et
mensonger et à partir de là l'actif des
politiques semblent aller dans le sens
de la réhabilitation de la revendication
posthume les gens comme franck et puis
on se sent de 3,64 je m'aperçois que ce
n'est pas vrai qu'il faut de nouveau
rappelé dans cette réunion du bureau
politique se souvenir de nous expliquer
pourquoi c'est là ce mensonge là elle
c'est la dernière fois qu'ils se
produira pour moi on va vous être dur
avec vous même vous l'être encore plus
avec santiago carillo pas encore plus
non je crois que le public peut vraiment
être dur avec lui même si j'arrive à
celui qui possède sa mémoire
donc c'est lui qui s'est beaucoup mieux
que moi là où le bât blesse oui mais là
c'est paraît surprenant puisque nous
évidemment qui tenait son si mal c'est
chose du parti comme espagnol on voit un
homme tout à fait elle renomme bonnes
âmes où le personnage et votre nuit tôt
noble qu on l'accuse plutôt de tourner
dans la droite maintenant et alors là
c'est un lien on peut associer leurs
effrayants des listes allié sûr toujours
tourné vers la droite
non mais vous l'accusez indirectement
d'avoir causé la mort de
non non non c'est plus précis que ça je
l'accuse d'avoir envoyé travailler en
espagne juan lima dans un groupe de
camarades dont je tais le responsable
sans que je sache moi qui étais le son
responsable qui il était quelle était
son passé sont passés de temps passé que
deux sur lequel je ne veux pas revenir
maintenant c'est un homme qui était
fusillé communiste absolument dévoués
qui a donc donné sa vie pour ses cours
sur cette bataille là mais son passé
d'être un passé de policier spéciale de
la république pendant la guerre civile
c'est à dire je ne suis pas en train de
discuter maintenant la nécessité d'une
police politique pendant une guerre
civile dans un état républicain
bon cela dit cet homme a poursuivi donc
les les agents de la cinquième colonne
franquiste
entre autres il ya aussi pour celui un
peu les gens du poum délais trop ce
qu'ils en espagnol pendant toute la
guerre civile c'est à dire que le noyau
de la police politique francky ce sont
deux les survivants de cette cinquième
colonne c'est à dire les hommes qui ont
souffert de cette police politique
envoyait travail à l'espagne quel point
dont on peut découvrir se passer c'est
l'envoyer à la vengeance personnelle
des hommes de la police politique
franquiste d'ailleurs regardez autour de
vous regardez l'histoire c'est le seul
dirigeant communiste qui a été fusillé
en espagne mais depuis je veux dire
depuis quarante-huit précise le seul le
seul parce qu'il y avait une motivation
personnelle
donc je ne juge pas d'avoir ensuite il
faut bien préciser chauvy avoir envoyé à
la mort j'accuse d'avoir avec seule
autorité de société générale cache est
l'élément essentiel en général tout les
gens qui veulent être partait travailler
quand les signes manger et examiner
leurs candidatures étaient examinés lors
dossier leur biographie est ce qui
pourrait résister ou pas en cas de déré
station est ce qu ils avaient tous là
pourquoi paris faisait partie de ce
groupe de fidèles inconditionnels de
kério alors c'est ça et je replonge une
autre chose c'est que comme par un excès
de zèle il commençait à devenir
imprudente et qu'il fallait le retirer
du travail clandestin on a mis trop
longtemps le faire et il est tombé
il a payé de sa vie c'est ça que je vous
raconte d'ailleurs personne n'a jamais
encore depuis six mois collectées
ce pagne essayer de démontrer que tenus
sur l'affirmation sur ce plan-là de
fourche
personne n'est carillonner personne
parce qu'on ne peut pas vous êtes sûr de
votre mémoire de ma mémoire des
documents il existe pourtant à la fin
c'est le dernier mot d'autres vivres
vous êtes prêté de l'intellectuel adepte
de la tête de linotte ça voulait dire
intellectuelle ce conclave à sa décharge
l'iton espagnol mais ça veut dire ça
veut dire intellectuel assis de jean
hatzfeld a littéralement ça ça veut dire
intellectuelle qui n'ont pas le sens de
la lutte des classes j'imagine qu'ils ne
connaissent pas la réalité de la
politique intellectuel fut maintenant tu
as lease réaliste et au fond vous était
aussi